yes that's right rocking and rolling and
rocking and rolling let's dive into the
yeah rhythm of the song welcome back
Jimmy's just smiling happy it's Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts and look who we
are joined by then Bailey welcome to the
show man thank you how are you I'm good
I'm uh I'm cold it's winter yeah
especially since I'm just gonna stay
warm all you know I'm like no we're
gonna get away with it somehow yeah it's
like 50 degrees on Friday yeah it was
like nice everything was fine
everything was fine 50 mile an hour
winds today are you sure yeah they're
gonna be gusting it was bad coming in
yesterday I flew home I zip back from
the coast I was in the I was in Florida
and it was a [ __ ] I always hate when
you're flying in there like the flight
ends are gonna be seated like for the
last 40 minutes of the flight you're
like oh this is gonna suck
did it suck there's a landing bad oh
it's the worst right yeah it was really
weird I was like I start getting nervous
sometimes like I'm gonna vomit that's
was I'm not scared of falling out of the
sky anymore I'm scared of vomiting yeah
I get to where if I fly enough I just
get to work nothing bothers me at all on
a Floyd I'm just totally tuned out you
don't care I had the worst landing like
you I think it's very similar what
you're talking about
I didn't land yesterday but I guess
about a week ago just we circled for 20
minutes where you know the planes
rocking back and forth were bouncing up
and down just horribly windy and I just
I was like well I've been flying a lot
that just didn't bother me at all
what do you do when you feel you sit
there I was reading yeah ignore
everything just didn't just didn't puff
but if like months go by and I don't fly
then I get on a flight I don't be
nervous uh I'd be like do these things
coat I was pretty big
okay that's not as bad big point is much
better yeah yeah they [ __ ] circling
when you think you're coming in and all
of a sudden like oh no we're banking
left and left we're making an oval all
country no we suck
Oh [ __ ] today gosh darn it all yeah I
would today's like the day that Donald
Trump walks around and go
like hey do we still believe in global
warming us pretty cold out is it not
favorite I'm sure he'll mention that
yeah course he will of course he will
handling things well on Twitter though I
think that's good for the president
elected between when Hamilton is [ __ ]
Christ inaccurately tweeting about him
okay right I was expecting to cast
yelled at pence but when they they
berated him I just like spoke very
kindly I thought they were very
respectful I was expecting to hear him
like she's like really [ __ ] on and I saw
it and the guy they thanked him for
coming and they're basically expressing
that they were nervous and and I didn't
think they were nasty to him at all they
could have been much the cast wasn't at
all because the crowd booed in the crowd
booed about what he gonna do told him
don't boo ya i'ma cast even intervened
so they said no booing here is Austin
tweeting like he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] happened yeah I think he just heard
what they said something he tends to be
reactionary our wonderful future vice
president wonderful wonder uh Mike Pence
was harassed last night at the theater
by the cast of Hamilton cameras blazing
this should not happen and then I also
believe that he said yes this is my
favorite the theater must always be a
safe and special place
the cast of Hamilton was very rude last
night to a very good man Mike Pence
apologized which is just to read a tweet
where the numbered like the non-pc
candidate right like the only reason
he's in office is because he's not PC
yeah he's talking about how the theater
should be a safe space yeah like what I
don't believe that he ever once in his
life felt that the theater was a safe
and phenomena you know you know he never
rolled over and just thought oh how I
love I feel unsafe today quick get me to
a play the hallowed grounds of the
Winter Garden it was inaccurate we did
it by the way when you're the vice
president and you're going somewhere day
of its sold out for two years
and you need a bunch of tickets in the
third row people say well he was just
kind of going
as a regular American that he wouldn't
have gotten those [ __ ] how about this
service secret so he called that
afternoon how really how about this when
you're the when you're the vice
president or you're about to be the vice
president and you're known as a guy who
kind of believes in the gay conversion
camps yes and it's not his it's not the
most gayness yeah yeah it's not the most
gay friendly politician of all time I
don't believe it's for gay marriage you
know it's definitely not for gay
marriage going to a Broadway show and
being surprised that some of the cast
has something to say to you it would be
weird if they didn't say anything to him
yeah I was just gonna say when you go
there and you can't do a more homosexual
thing than go to a Broadway play that's
it it's the most homosexual thing you
can do that's it you're basically in
you're in a vat of homosexuals don't be
surprised when they they're not happy to
see you yeah well they know your stance
they know that you're anti-gay right I
don't and I know that he did they said
well he signed that thing to protect the
gay and lesbian people in Indiana he did
but I think that was kind of he was
reluctant but he did sign that one thing
that protected them from discrimination
when people are doing things in order
and their religion like you can't
discriminate because your religion
against someone because they're gay so
he did sign that he hasn't been I think
completely horrible but he's a feels
pretty good you know about that I don't
know much about the guy honestly I know
he's he's known as an enemy of the gay
community which is odd cause good thing
I really know about him right Yeah right
he looks like a guy who hates gay people
so much they're gonna find a murdered
male prostitute in his trunk looks like
they're gonna find one who smothered
with cigarette burns on him just as
nipples bitten off Mike Pence on a boner
I know he's a good man I apologize
here's the so the rumor and this is from
Snopes is that Mike Pence supported gay
conversion therapy which involves the
use of electroshock therapy by the way
with a zap you until you're not gay
anymore that comes how you say okay I'm
not getting mad just [ __ ] thing off my
head yeah just bring me a [ __ ] fine
yeah but when you have that state
and it comes back it's a mixture it's
not true but it's not false he mic pants
once supported the use of federal
funding to treat people seeking to
change their sexual behavior law is that
only for being gay or because that's
actually a good thing if you do this I
mean know if it's treating their sexual
behavior like say you're sexually
compulsively you're cheating on your
wife I think you're [ __ ] different
girls at work does he mean all that
stuff anyway I'm sure it's religious
based may be seeking gay cam sexual
behavior that's just people who want to
get laid I need to go to virgin
conversion therapy I mean that's a thing
anything that you read you can you could
spin it around into you know whenever
you want anything at all yeah let's play
white as votes for federal funding for
people who need to get laid but he never
said it but in my charts he never said
he supported the use of electric shocks
were gay conversion therapy okay so
that's a guy that's false let's hire Sam
he definitely did let's know you didn't
let's hear what the we are
right sir but we truly want the
Destroyers inspired to uphold our
American values and to work on behalf of
all of us
[Applause]
this wonderful American story told by a
diverse group of men and women of
different colors creeds and
[Applause]
yeah I didn't think that was
particularly hateful and like we wasn't
like when you're when you're Trump and
you've said some inflammatory things and
that's part of your appeal when
something like this happens the best
response would have been the play was
amazing and we intend to be a president
and a vice president for all Americans
like you not know how to put out a
[ __ ] fire right Christ right you just
go and go like you know their concern I
get that they're concerned and there
will be satisfied or they're gonna be
happy or we are gonna protect them or
yes I hear you
we'll look after you that's it all about
but I hate that guy's dialect though
well he's doing it let me tell you
something everybody like singsong he
like yeah nonsense of Hamilton but I
didn't think that that was that could
have been really vicious it wasn't and
the crowd would have cheered but that
was that but that wasn't I told you
don't hear it on that but he did tell
people no and there's no booing here
yeah and he said we hope we've inspired
you but people are nervous about it and
yeah a pro-life conservative
vice-president and a president who said
some you know some for Mike Pence to
come too harsh they made Broadway show
in the middle of New York City lake
obviously that that's a thing you have
to say something it would be I would
show a lack of integrity if the Hamilton
people didn't well I like that they did
a turn in the curtain call true they
didn't interrupt the show yeah yeah and
they told the crowds to stop booing him
yeah I I disagree that that was harsh
yeah I don't think it was harsh at all
all let's go to Marv got off easy
yeah I'll try to get him back in there
today go in there and watch rent mark in
South Carolina welcome to Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Ben Bailey is here
oh well good morning gentlemen little
teeny I just wanted to say I love you on
that camp you're amazing I haven't heard
you talk enough about that
thank you I haven't seen it so I haven't
talked about yeah I did that what's
night care it's a show about a fictional
talk-show about the book of a fictional
talk show and I did I think the first
episode and that was with Gwyneth
Paltrow and I guess it aired but I
haven't seen it yeah it was good she was
fun
yeah especially when when it's offered
to give you a [ __ ] that was I almost
busted a nut myself oh yes she did I get
a lot of that we did the script and then
there was a few lines that were off that
they actually kept in I saw like a
little one-minute teaser video and a
couple of the improv lines they left in
but I have my stuff with her she was
actually just asking you to give you a
[ __ ] and you yeah I don't know the
cameras are rolling the creditor offered
to give you a [ __ ] and you forgot it
yeah yeah they were certain I will never
forget that that might have been
adjusted but I saw one minute teaser
video that showed part of my stuff and
part of everyone else's but they didn't
show any of my stuff with Gwyneth yeah
but it was it was really good it was the
second
it was the second episode or something
you see okay it was very good anyway
going back to the original point that
you guys were making yeah I agree with
the way he said it was very polite and
very nice but I will agree with steven
van zandt
will Stevie from Bruce Springsteen's
band where he said that was totally
uncalled for
because when someone goes to a play they
expect to be entertained not spoken to
singled out or lectured and you know
what there's a time and a place for
everything
the theatre is supposed to be a safe
place where you can actually relax and
get into the performance and enjoy and
they made the spotlight turn on the
fight they did well how about this how
about the guy doesn't get the ticket
seat like when you're a conservative VP
and you've taken that stance you can't
expect to get [ __ ] 12 tickets in the
middle of the room crowded already booed
him like the cast decided to just call
him out and it was the end of the show
you're addressing the situation I've
taken it I thought they handled it well
they they literally had a sty like he
was leaving walking out because the show
was over and they're like wait before
you go and they said they're leaving
that's a security reason that he's
leaving before everyone else understand
yeah that's fine that he was leaving
before everybody else but the plaza they
also changed some of the lyrics
poking at the administration and
the thing is once it goes that they
worry you know what
it wasn't my tents that was going there
then oh my god I can't believe it was
the Vice president-elect that's how he
was able to give the tickets now might
as the person you know what I you know
what if you are going outside and debate
him or talk to him that's fine but don't
single him out in finish what happened
when the cast came out there and gave
their speech that was the I'm holier
than thou please listen I have the forum
I'm gonna put the spotlight on you and
tell you exactly how you should be think
you know what [ __ ] Mike Pence you just
convincing me that they did the right
thing wait I know what you're saying
dude and if they were really read it
don't like if they were really rude to
that right if they said to him your
administration is garbage I would be a
hundred percent with you but after they
said that is the bottom line is he's
gonna make decision this is not a guy
who just said something politically
incorrect
he's a varies a man with power to make
decisions over your life it's a little
different when you're a politician you
have the ability to affect people's
lives but by decisions you make in ways
you you vote and things you do I have no
problem with after seeing it and as far
as enjoying it as far as enjoying it
privately like he volunteered for the
position to be the biggest problem the
second biggest public figure in America
if not arguably one of the biggest
public figures in the world yes going
you keep fallin tiered to take the
morning show from Opie really no yes we
did want you to do this yes yes if I
went if I was out and somebody was like
oh you're Sam you have a morning show I
know who you are you don't know who I am
but I have an opinion about you I
wouldn't sit there and be like you don't
have a right to have an opinion about me
I'd say yeah I've volunteered to sort
myself out yeah we've all just business
okay you would never you never when
someone has a critical opinion of you or
you get pissed off you hang up and say
that's it I've had enough this time
there's time to do that the difference
is the difference I don't have the
ability Sam doesn't have the ability Ben
to make decisions on your life I haven't
been been passing legislation or
fighting for legislation that's gonna
change marks life there's that was a
huge version
there's a difference dude when you when
you're the vice president United States
and there's also a different respect
level that you should be spoken to and
I'm telling you when I first clicked on
that I was expecting to be annoyed like
I'll grate these [ __ ] liberal people
just attack the conservative but then I
saw the way they talked to him and they
were expressing concern and will you be
art like they were basically saying for
all of us like we're real here
they said honored to have him there and
after the stuff Trump has said he has
said some things that would cause
concern if you're in one of those groups
come on
absolutely and they don't they feel
vulnerable and it's not hypocritical for
Donald Trump to say like that should be
a safe sacred space come on yeah that
shouldn't have any Lea's here well yeah
we're not do I'm not I don't like
parents I don't like him I you know I
really don't love the guy because he's
too conservative and I don't think he
likes to be humiliated in public but I
think the administration this is what's
annoying me about this already you have
an opportunity to take that moment or
with these protesters and go I hear what
you're afraid of you don't have to be
afraid it's like hey dumb [ __ ]
it's not always a win loss yeah you got
the job yeah you definitely could have
done something like that and the whole
everything would have been different yes
we heard about would be different you
can use that to your advantage you know
Mike Pence can go hey they spoke their
minds I'm there I'm their vice president
and they spoke to me and they were
respectful it like what the [ __ ] I think
he should have stood up and broken into
song himself well I think and I guess
the thing is that bothers me is that
they won the election they got the
electoral college
that means the country has chosen them
now you know what they don't like this
position well then they should have got
more people to vote the other way it's a
done deal president they're saying just
so you know this is how we feel and we
want you to hear us and dude can't you
just say yeah good I'm sure that's the
very first time you ever ever heard that
but again aren't you aren't you I
guarantee you this
you like Trump and Mike Pence right well
not really
so you got okay all right so you don't
think that he should have been talked to
that way like you wouldn't feel you feel
the same way even if it was Obama being
spoken to by a play oh absolutely
because the respectability of the office
itself not the person the office itself
well I don't think that they were
particularly disrespect yeah I was
expecting some maybe because I was
expecting something different when I
clicked on I totally was I thought it
was gonna be like horrible yeah they're
gonna be like don't care about [ __ ] you
but yeah they were like they were they
said they were honored to have him there
and there basically was just like we're
worried man yeah minorities we're
worried about what's gonna happen when
your administration and there's there's
a big sorry yeah there's a view there's
a big difference between like insulting
people and shouting about it and saying
this is wrong and saying you're not our
president and dah dah dah and then
seeing the guy face to face and saying
hey no no no none of that none of the
booing stuff none of the insulting stuff
this is where we're coming from yeah and
I think that's what they were doing but
they handled it well you know whether
you don't have to intense wasn't
offended no he was not he was not offend
because he's a guy who understands that
that's what you do in that moment like
he's been in this game long enough right
and note that you come out of that
saying the play was great and I heard
what they say and I wasn't offended yeah
Donald on the other hand picked up his
Twitter account I like I liked these
honest Trump I like to these speeches of
mine and says things that people don't
like but this is just a little yeah it's
petty
and it's wrong it's reading it wrong
it's a dude you dumbbell you got an
opportunity now to [ __ ] win people
over who might have been annoyed with
you yeah like this is a gift the fact
that they're doing this is a [ __ ]
gift if you're if you're this if you're
Trump and everyone's protesting you
right and then the cast of the biggest
play on the [ __ ] planet comes out and
says this and you say you have nothing
to be afraid of we're going to be a
great like that's pretty reading
everybody together right and instead he
reacted quickly without really seemingly
knowing what happened and and you know
seemingly push people further apart and
now the story is his tweet and not Mike
Pence's response yeah
the other parent is responsible actually
I'm gonna hear Mike response my really
funny queued up big birds I want to hear
Mike's what it might say when the place
gonna say you say that now the story is
about his tweet but do you think that
he's doing this consciously to get the
Trump University stuff out of the
picture because nobody's talking about
that oh there was a lot of maybe that it
was all you know smokes a ruse 74
remaining lawsuit I'll see you go
maybe Travis might be I love that but
enough of that let's get back to this
Hamilton thing but yeah you might be
right there you have people suggesting
that on social media right I would love
to know I would love to know like where
Trump lands on that scale of like 5 to
60 I would love to know where he lands
on that scale of nefarious versus
impulsive like is this just a guy who's
impulsive or is he a little more
methodical than people give him credit
for because I mean that's that's the
question right like it's a pretty
impulsive kind of angry and irrational
thing to do to just throw this tweet out
and say [ __ ] you I love Mike Pence but
yeah it's pretty methodical and
well-thought-out to be like oh this will
be a good story to distract people I
honestly don't think that he's thinking
about it that much right I don't think
he's worried about this stuff I think
he's just like he's pretty sure he's
gonna win anyway he's just like yeah he
couldn't his belief that he can do no
wrong is like ironclad right now right
so he's just I think he honestly just
reacted yeah why what do you mean they
booed pence yeah damn I'm gonna tweet
about it right now I think you're right
several advisors like let's think about
this house [ __ ] off leave me alone I
really want Trump to be different than
everyone like you're like I'm not anti
Trump at all I really want him to do
well like I want him to be like a
surprise like oh my god we thought he
was gonna be terrible and he's not like
you know a lot of people - I totally
agree with you jr. I just wish he would
stop with the Twitter that's all it's
bothered me so far not his [ __ ]
choices just stop
Twitter's yes thank
right leader of the free world at least
say it differently not Milania and mrs.
Oh had a great time exclamation defended
you for a year
I'm saying stop stop tweeting maybe he's
gonna he'll get in and he'll get ma who
really want to you know bring about this
all this change that he's talking I'm
afraid will really want like I feel like
if Bernie had won the Democratic
nomination he might be a president right
now very well
and if Joe Biden run I think he would
Biden would have won Bernie would I
don't think birdie know didn't really
know I'd like people want to change so
badly that that's why I don't know about
Bernie because they were saying like
maybe okay thanks they were saying
statistically that like a lot of Obama
vote people who voted for Obama there
was a surprising number of them that
ended up voting for Trump and I think
that that does go to the change thing
that people wanted so who knows maybe
all those people who voted for Obama
would have voted for Bernie instead of
Trump right all right and all the
Hillary people would have voted for is
that what you think exactly so then it
would have been yeah Bernie right
possibly I guess they showed me what did
you give it a tap instead of a press or
a push whatever I did I literally I've
gotten more [ __ ] response tapping my
windows at home nothing happened
do you want to get a whole bag of tricks
over there on I want to hear Mike you
wanna hear Mike response response yeah
yeah and I think that should be more the
story minute left and I gotta ask you
about the subject everybody is talking
about today you know what it is and that
is the fact that you went to see the
Broadway musical Hamilton on Friday
night and afterwards that the cast
addressed you as you were walking out of
the theater about their concerns as to
whether mr. Trump will protect diversity
in our nation here he is
[Music]
now Saturday morning mr. Trump tweeted
this the cast of Hamilton was very rude
last night to a very good man Mike Pence
apologized and he dated about it again
at 6:23 this morning governor why don't
you think of the cast comments and did
you consider it rude
well first off my daughter and I and her
and her cousins really enjoyed the show
Hamilton is just an incredible
production and incredibly talented
people and it was a real joy to be there
and you know when we arrived we heard we
heard a few boos and we heard some
cheers and I you know hear me cheers I
did them that's what freedom sounds like
and but at the end I you know I was that
for a second here's what happened it was
just booze and then he sarcastically
said I guess that's what freedom sounds
like shifting this to now there's cheers
cheers Cheers
coming from the cousins yeah you know
what freedom so this is kind of the way
you got to take that you know yes we're
gonna like you're gonna hate yeah of
course yeah yeah that's a good point of
course go ahead from the stage and I can
tell you I wasn't offended by what was
said I'll leave to others whether that
was the appropriate venue to say it but
I do want to say that that the the basic
element is the center of that message is
one that I I want to address and that is
I I know this is a very disappointing
time for people that that did not see
their candidate win in this national
election I know this is a very time for
some people and I just want to reassure
people that what president elect Donald
Trump said on election night he
absolutely meant from the bottom of his
heart he is preparing to be the
president executive of America and to
watch him bringing together people of
diverse views bringing together people
that differed with him strongly seeing
him talk to leaders around the world
I just want her I just want to reassure
every American that that in the days
ahead I'm very confident that they're
gonna see they're gonna see president
elect Donald Trump and be a president
for all of the people and and we embrace
that principle and we're gonna work hard
to make that principle that's a great
response and that should have been the
story that should have been the story
that Trump tweeted instead of you know I
mean if the reaction is so stupid the
beginning middle and end of it right
there yeah that's a great job yeah yeah
he did he did it right here's an
opportunity to reach out to these people
and and and tell them it's all right and
I guess that's where I do like I guess
that's where a seasoned politician does
yeah kind of work or guy knows like this
is how you handle it as opposed to but
it's not even like a seasoned politician
it's just like you have just watched
politicians for the years that you've
been alive and you're aware enough to
know that that would be how one respond
I'm a seasoned man
you're a seasoned man well I don't know
yeah you just know seasoned thank you
yeah what does that mean how many that
last call yet so did you guys plan on
you took the morning show from lashing
out you got upset really wanted us to
agree with him
yeah what's gonna happen when we do what
are gonna happen uh Ben Bailey what's up
I've got a new special I do yeah that's
available now on the real Ben Bailey
calm or on iTunes yep or Amazon or you
know it's kind of all over the place
yeah best buy all that stuff you didn't
go with a network at all no I didn't I
produced it myself that's all and thanks
man
and I Ted wasn't totally sure what to do
with it and I'm not great at the selling
part of anything and then I was like you
know what my website really needs to be
overhauled and everything's changed
since I put it up years ago and so I was
like you know what I'm just gonna put it
up on mine so basically it's on my side
with a whole bunch of other stuff and
that's pretty that's pretty much it so
it's like a good reason to redesign your
website let me put a special up there I
can get a nice website redesign yeah
well I needed to do I need to redo it
anyway and I just it feels like now you
can just create your own content and and
put it straight out so yeah that's what
I'm doing and you got two podcasts to
tauba true with Colin as your first
guest and speaking of movies with Emma
Gleeson alright so you like what we you
haven't been like that social media
active doing this stuff and I just like
[ __ ] I'm gonna do it yeah totally I
like I I Cash Cab came and went for me
and it was that that was Oh 5 to 12 by 7
years no he did it for 8 years from 2004
to 2012 real nice run oh thanks yeah it
was great but everything changed like
before Cash Cab there was no Twitter
it's right there was no like people were
not big into social media like him right
and then it ended and I was like oh my
god everybody it everything's changed
yeah everybody has a show yeah their own
show and I was reluctant I was like I
don't know what to do and then I don't
know after a few years of trying to
pitch things trying to land something I
was like well I am why am I still trying
to sell my stuff right why don't I just
go ahead and make it it created and see
what comes from that right now I can get
it right out to the people who actually
want to see it and so that's what I've
done the last few years I've been
working hard on getting the podcast
ideas straightened out I don't want to
just do something just to do something
under wait till I was inspired right
Jimmy maybe you remember DC Benny and I
used to do that show urban myth it's
like a story telling years ago it's like
we did every Tuesday for like 5 years
and it was everybody came through it was
great so that's basically what tall
about true is it's just a storytelling
show okay I like the two of us co-host
and then we have a guest come in tell
her he's doing the Sabbath cover band
yes I am yeah I played in a while
because I've been so busy with this
other stuff but yeah definitely I love
that Ben who like really who asked me
that Sabbath how many years ago is that
I started not a CD it's gotta be six
seven years ago that's one of my
greatest accomplishments as a man and I
got Ben Bailey in a Black Sabbath
dude I was I went to a bachelor party
down in Atlantic City and the only guy
that brought music brought all Sabbath
uh and for the first couple hours I was
like all right
not for this [ __ ] Sabbath man get it
you like stab like two hours later was
like these guys are [ __ ] amazing holy
Sh it's totally turned and then I died
literally didn't listen to anything but
Sabbath for like for like three straight
years yeah nothing but and that's when I
was all over you because I know you were
huge what do you recommend is a CD and
I'm like I just started handing over
cities and giving them away just brought
bottom and brought him to me oh yeah the
celery probably a whole stack of them
he's like here's what you should start
with can you imagine anything amazing
having a band like that that still picks
up new fans
you know what I mean that somebody can
still discover a Black Sabbath and
become obsessed with them from just
happy to be on a radio show that picks
up no fans unbelievable and I was right
there seventies right in there yeah
plus they had thirteen was like their
that was their biggest album ever in the
u.s. yeah I loved it yeah it's so good
I'm really just getting into it now like
I didn't I didn't want to listen to it
then it was like I want to stay with the
old stuff I uh I can't do it and but I
was on I did this tour I did a bunch of
air force bases through October domestic
basically I did like 12 of them and I
just had it in my phone so I just
listened are you doing stand-up yeah and
like really got into it man damaged soul
is [ __ ] amazing my favorite [ __ ]
singer Chris my favorite thing and that
was one I asked Accio that Rick Rubin
just said that was a warm-up thing
they're doing there was a song there
called damaged soul and that was just a
riff they were playing and warm-up and
Rick Rubin says gotta do something with
that and that's why he's like I had the
lyrics I don't love the lyrics in that
because it was a very last minute song
that wasn't supposed to be on the album
it's the best album that's interesting
yeah it was just like they would they
would do these warm-up riffs around an
hour and Rick grew and just knew it was
good yeah that's where it comes in handy
good he's okay that sort of thing it's
not bad at all and they were talking you
were talking before Ben came in about
his performance
years back at the Patrice O'Neal Rose
yeah I read something out that recently
people just really he'll love that yeah
they'll still go and find that so I
don't know where it's up yeah I don't
know where it is either but I've gotten
like a fair amount of social media and
stuff people tweet about it and talk
about it that was like one of my that
was a big night for me man that was like
you guys didn't see me coming I don't
think no no roasts
I was nervous about it so I really wrote
like I think if we gonna do a roast you
really have to write about he got a he
can't just go in and you know make you
could make it look off-the-cuff maybe
but you can't just wing it
yeah research write a bunch of jokes and
yeah yeah not with not with this group
you know the good guys that were on that
one and are you the murdering everyone
everyone that was really funny
yeah asset to it I listen to a little
bit of it I was like holy [ __ ] that I
thought could say that so mean I never I
think Mousavi ax had that audio or
whatever it was that from when I hit the
Jim Norton Rose I don't know who had
that one that was a great roast to
account that was awesome yeah that was
harsh man some things were hard yeah
that one who was on that huge Colin
Geraldo Bob levy who else on anything
Nick was on it well Patrice was on it
grace Florentine Florentine yeah that
was that was a great night man but Sofia
recorded that with like we had like a
four camera shoot going Patrice's that
is gross yeah oh but that's never been
out just the audio has been released
that's weird
yeah they'll go to the trouble of
shooting it like that and then just not
do I didn't remember there's a four
cameras yeah I showed it at the stand
one night the people like it yeah I
guess but I like nobody knew about it I
know I didn't know about it it's one of
those lost tapes what's not lost if he
has it I mean I got to the audience
sound yes yeah sounds lost and found
yeah we did it all lost and found we did
it all right here
oh that look that clip looks like it's
from your roast you mean that is that
bill it says bill Barrett Patrice O'Neal
but that's in Caroline that one yeah
[ __ ] me spill on it he was on the other
one he's up Patrice as I know I think
use play on both it's amazing like kind
of what's happened with everybody since
then yeah I'm just looking at the dais
and being like wow in 2000 we did the
Barry Katz roast yeah and I remember
Louie I think Jeff Ross hosted it I
remember Louie coming on just being so
[ __ ] mean he goes how are you
successful with those poems no kidding
yeah he's just saying things that were
mean yeah these mean the power you got
about and you suck as a manager I have
yeah what he said I've been very
unpleasant yeah I think you can find
video of that if you publish that oh my
god
Patrice under Barry oh my god there is
video this oh yeah my students shot this
dumb I filmed it Voss that's amazing
it's the whole Boston Comedy Club I just
saw Voss yesterday's we're in that same
suit what years ago oh my god I've never
seen this no I haven't either crazy do
you wanna listen
yeah I didn't really um man that's rough
raisi it's rough man I still feel like
some of the just like all the sudden
people we knew just started [ __ ] you
get old they drop dead dying [ __ ]
going on yeah well you don't think about
it and it sort of feels like there's
maybe still there just out on the road
or something yeah I think right let's
see you don't see everybody else anymore
no not seen yeah oh yeah I haven't seen
so-and-so in five months then you're
like oh yeah he's dead that's why
rooting for me to see him soon and I
talked about Patrice a lot on stage
there's an incident that he and I had it
was oh it was a fun moment in Brazil
that I mentioned on stage so it's not
like he's been out of my mind right but
then you see something that you haven't
seen years ago you say that with such
cheer it sounds like it it probably
might not involve young hookers very
very family Christmas know you're always
wearing my Charles Haley Jersey in this
one look so cool one thing about you you
like jerseys always agree with you
because you have such a natural athletic
build it's funny you say that a lot of
people don't shoulder pads but other
than that it looks like it could shape
these days these days not those days
back then yeah I think back then darker
hair yeah yeah more Chin's yeah I was a
fatter boy one extra juicy lower lip
Jesus Christ they went to Cox love me
look at that juicy lower lip but you
have that chin there but look at the way
your cheeks just blend to your neck yes
never seen anything like that roll right
in there on the sides right by the ears
there yeah there's I've comment a lot
yeah have you
I don't think a fleshie celery stalk
it's like somebody just took the
Photoshop blur tool I'm Tara I got 528
views on that puppy Wow and Jimmy it's
only been others making money it's only
been up for two years
thumbs up boy Jimbo - thumbs up - Jimbo
yeah - and out right now as far as
reviewers go boy well boy like tearing
that [ __ ] up I haven't seen that in so
long I'm almost embarrassed to see
what's on man I'm afraid like old
stand-up I don't think I've heard that
since it's been out maybe I've heard it
in the years since but I don't remember
yeah but then Bailey we can get your
special at the real Ben Bailey calm we
can follow you at real Ben Bailey you
can also get the special on iTunes and
Amazon it's called Ben Bailey live and
uncensored and if you want to if you
want to sample it right and then
download the podcast he just started -
new podcast called tall but true and
another one called speaking of movies
and there's a really funny stand up and
you know it's hard for you to say it
happen I mean there's a comic now you're
a really good act and if you want to
check out Ben special and then check out
live dates
he's got dates in Peoria Illinois which
is Richard Pryor's hometown the
connection in Rhode Island and I got a
couple of different places in Michigan
so go to the real Ben Bailey dot-com to
get his dates pens are really funny out
yes and I'm happy to see you buddy
thanks man joy so we'll see you soon
okay all right absolute